tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel
conséquence du mauvais temps un mois de
retard pour les cultures des prix trop
élevés sur les marchés pour la saison
sports d'hiver plus qu'une dizaine de
sites vierges dans les montagnes coup
d'arrêt confirmé aux stations béton
élections législatives de mai en grande
bretagne
la question européenne jouera un grand
jeu premier match etats unis france de
football cette nuit à new york
les tricolores joueront en chaussures de
tennis sur une pelouse synthétique
bonsoir pour un peu on finirait par ne
plus oser vous parler du temps qu'il
fait tellement on ne voit pas le bout de
ce deuxième hiver en plein printemps il
a gelé ce matin à rostronen en bretagne
le gel menace aussi dans le massif
central il n'a pas fait aussi froid
depuis 1945 à la même époque en
normandie dans les vosges et dans la
région parisienne les chasse neige
non pardon il a fait il a neigé et les
chasse-neige sont entrés en action sur
le versant alsacien des vosges où l'on
s'est réveillée avec 10 à 20 centimètres
de neige fraîche
il a neigé également mais cela a vite
fondu en picardie en normandie est un
peu partout même à paris encore tout à
l'heure ce froid nous vient du groënland
et de l'islande il est accompagné de
forts coups de vent et même de tempête
en mer un chalutier de saint vaast la
hougue
dans la manche le john kennedy a fait
naufrage hier et ses sept marins ont été
récupérés ce matin par un cargo comme on
l'imaginé sept marins étaient transis de
froid les vents resteront très fort
demain sur les côtes de la manche et de
la mer du nord et le mistral soufflera
sur les régions méditerranéennes les
seuls qui bénéficieront d'ailleurs de
belles éclaircies avec une température
convenable
partout ailleurs ce sera pire
qu'aujourd'hui avec des températures
encore en baisse et des gelées prévu le
matin dans le centre le nord est et la
région parisienne
dans la journée le ciel restera très
nuageux avec
les averses de pluie de grêle et de
neige et dans l'almanach de michel le
jardinier de michel lis et de michel
barbier préfacé par pierre perret
d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé ces trois dicton
quand il pleut le premier jour de mai
les vaches perte de la moitié de leur
lait c'est ce qu'on dit dans le poitou
dans le nord on dit que mes froid
n'enrichit personnes et ailleurs qu'au
mois de mai il faudrait qu'il ne plus
jamais pourtant michel le jardinier
rappelle que jusqu'à la mi-mai il ne
faut semer qu'avec précaution tant que
les gelées sont à craindre
c'est un conseil valable tous les ans
cela dit le jardin c'est une chose
l'agriculture c'en est une autre et si
la série culte heures ne dramatise pas
encore la situation
il commence quand même à se faire du
souci les consommateurs aussi jean
françois robinet car c'est ce qu'on voit
sur les marchés les prix des fruits et
des et des légumes sont tout à fait
prohibitif pour la saison oui disons que
ces prix sont encore beaucoup trop élevé
pour la saison mais comme vous le disiez
de quelle saison s'agit-il
ce sont plutôt des prix d'automne que
des prix de printemps il ya en fait
exactement un mois de retard et en plus
en avril et en mai la distribution est
très contrarié par les vacances
scolaires par les ponts qui sont
fréquents on achète plus de légumes
frais lorsque on est de congé et cela
pour faire des salades variées pour
faire des petits pots aux lardons des
radis et des concombres lorsqu'on reçoit
des amis un petit panorama sur un marché
va nous montrer les prix et on a vu que
les poireaux sont encore très cher les
voici 7 francs 50 à 9 30 kg c'est la
conséquence du gel de cet hiver les
artichauts et aussi son cher les endives
en revanche ont baissé ainsi que les
salades mais les tomates sont elles très
cher puisqu'elles vont jusqu'à 14h
francs le kilo alors en plein hiver on
trouvait des tomates à 6 francs le kilo
aujourd'hui début du printemps on trouve
les tomates de 11 à 14 oui mais ça c'est
parce que les importations du maroc sont
arrêtées elles sont limitées par un
calendrier pour ne pas gêner les
productions du marché commun mais les
tomates de serre hollandaise temps
tarder à entrer en production et les
espagnols valent encore très cher les
pommes de terre on vient de le voir les
pommes de terre primaire 3 350 les
françaises ne seront en production que
vers le 15 mai mais il reste tout de
même des pommes de terre de neige
hier des beach autour de la fronde kg et
moins tout de même un fruit qui est
intéressant c'est la fraise qui commence
à être cueillies dans le roussillon et
en provence et qui vient aussi à la fois
d'espagne et d'italie
ces prix sont relativement intéressant
dans le panier de la ménagère on peut
donc mettre assez bon marché les fraises
les endives les radis que voici cueilli
actuellement dans le midi les salades
ces images nous montrent donc où en est
la production actuellement en france les
radis qui sont tout à fait de saison
et puis nous allons le voir dans les
serres des haricots qui ne produiront
pas avant un bon mois c'est le retard
qui inquiète effectivement les
maraîchers les agriculteurs bon alors
maintenant il ya les répercussions
possibles de ce mauvais temps du temps
d'aujourd'hui et de demain sur les
champs et sur les vergers sur les arbres
fruitiers sur les céréales par exemple
après qu'est ce qu'on en pense dans les
milieux agricoles il ya un retard de
végétation qui ne doit pas être trop
grave pour les arbres fruitiers s'il n'y
a pas de geler en effet vous le disiez
tout à l'heure les gelées de printemps
sont d'autant plus dangereuses que la
végétation est avancé et cette
végétation est en retard pour les
céréales on peut déjà dire que près de
800 mille hectares de blé deux cent
mille hectares d'orge ont été détruits
par le gel cet hiver il a été ensuite
souvent difficile de ressemer en raison
de l'humidité c'est le cas en ce moment
et on peut déjà estimer que la
production 79 sera de 15 % - inférieure
à celle de 78 quelques chiffres la
moyenne était de 45 quintaux à l'hectare
elle devrait descendre en dessous de 40
quintaux et de près de 14 milliards de
francs la récolte descendra en dessous
de 11 milliards
donc 3 milliards de francs de manque à
gagner sans compter les frais
supplémentaires de semis et de travail
du sol
à moins que l'arrière saison ne soit
vraiment exceptionnel et puis que les
cours mondiaux nouveau et dans le ce qui
compensera ces pertes d'accord bien
alors nous restons dans le domaine
agricole mais à une toute autre échelle
avec la loi d'orientation adopté ce
matin par le conseil des ministres la
politique agricole du pays car il y en a
une
repose sur une loi de 1960
c'est grâce à cette première loi
d'orientation que notre réguler
l'agriculture s'est beaucoup développée
jusqu'à produire des excédents
d'ailleurs on en a même parlé à une
certaine époque on en a parlé on a parlé
de limiter la production agricole et
c'était dans le
le plan européen de monsieur mansholt
qui a soulevé beaucoup de tempêtes chez
nous le projet de loi d'orientation
d'aujourd'hui 79 qui sera examiné par le
parlement sans doute assez vite a pour
objet de faire franchir une nouvelle
étape au développement de l'agriculture
notamment en stabilisant la population
rurale en améliorant l'emploi en
augmentant leurs revenus des producteurs
ce qu'il souhaite bien sûr et en
poussant à la vente des produits
agricoles l'extérieur alors à nouveau
avec vous jean françois robinet les
grands axes de ce projet de loi
d'orientation pour l'agriculture avec
une valeur ajoutée de 83 milliards de
francs elle a doublé ces dix dernières
années la france a le plus gros chiffre
d'affaires agricole de la communauté
européenne mais elle n'est qu'à la
cinquième place pour la valeur ajoutée
par exploitation
le marché commun offert à la france de
vastes débouché depuis 20 ans mais il
devient de plus en plus autosuffisant
d'où la nécessité de trouver de nouveaux
débouchés
afin de pouvoir poursuivre l'expansion
c'est en effet l'orientation politique
nouvelle de cette loi plus question de
limiter les possibilités de production
mais à condition de mieux vendre et pour
cela un fonds de promotion des produits
agricoles va être créé
il sera géré par la profession et devra
favoriser l'exportation en 1978 après
plusieurs années de déficit
notre balance extérieure agricole est
redevenue positive
l'objectif reste d'atteindre très vite
les 20 milliards d'excédents autre point
politique fondamentale le maintien de la
population rurale
le texte proposé au parlement inscrits
l'activité agricole comme une priorité
de l'aménagement de l'espace rural
cela veut dire plus de rigidité dans les
plans d'occupation des sols et des
freins à la spéculation foncière
en même temps l'installation des jeunes
sera facilitée par un nouveau régime des
successions en agriculture et le
développement des groupements fonciers
agricoles faisant appel à l'épargné pour
des placements dans la terre enfin
l'agriculture doit être un secteur
créateur d'emplois
pour cela la formation va être développé
quatre cent cinquante mille élèves ou
stagiaires sont en formation chaque
année mais 60% des chefs d'exploitation
de moins de 35 ans n'ont encore aucune
formation agricole
une lacune qu'il est urgent de combler
au moment où l'on veut refaire de
l'agriculture l'activité économique et
industriel de base de notre espace rural
vous l'avez déjà souvent entendu ces
temps ci la solution de la crise de
l'emploi exige une réadaptation profonde
de l'économie française aux changements
du monde qui constitue le troisième défi
à relever depuis la guerre après la
reconstruction du pays et l'ouverture
vers l'europe
c'est le thème central du 8e plan pour
la période 81 85 et qui est en cours de
discussion en ce moment même au conseil
économique et social en présence de
raymond barre dans son rapport sur le
projet du gouvernement le conseil
économique et social reconnaît un effort
de réalisme mais il formule des
critiques sur le manque d'un grand
dessein pour mobiliser les français et
le conseil économique et social fait une
série de propositions pour donner la
priorité absolue aux problèmes de
l'emploi
alors avant d'écouter un extrait du
premier ministre non je pense que nous
n'aurons pas l'extrait du populiste
emmanuel de la taille rappelle qu'à
l'engagement 85 8e plan est dominé par
une forte odeur de pétrole et le tumulte
de bouleversements mondiaux
il donne une clé d'avenir une
gigantesque de modernisation
industrielle pour permettre à la france
devrait accélérer la croissance du
niveau de vie et de l'emploi en
surmontant deux défis extérieurs le prix
du pétrole et la multiplication des
concurrents en voici le schéma simplifié
premier défi la france ne peut payer une
facture de pétrole et de matières
premières de plus en plus lourde qu'en
exportant sans cesse davantage pour
trouver plus de devises et échapper au
piège du déficit extérieur
deuxième défi justement pour exporter la
bataille devient de plus en plus rude
car partout surgissent de nouveaux
concurrents qui peuvent fabriquer et
vendre la même chose que nous exemple de
cette mutation mondiale fin de l'énergie
à bon marché et de nous anciens
monopoles de fabrication la corée du sud
qui parti de rien pour adam cinq ans
produire autant d'acier que la france
une armée de voitures de tv et de
bateaux quel est l'impact de ce double
défi
la france est prise en tenaille entre la
facture du pétrole qui augmentent nos
coûts de production
alors que la nouvelle concurrence
diminue les prix de vente ne rien
changer aurait abouti à nous faire
éliminer du marché pour sombrer dans la
dépression
comment dès lors pas revenir à pousser
notre croissance malgré le handicap du
pétrole et le matraquage de la
concurrence le huitième plan fixe trois
conditions de base moderniser une
puissance économique capable de
conquérir partout des débouchés avec des
coûts de production de combat avoir une
monnaie forte de façon à payer moins
cher nos importations et a gagné plus de
devises avec nos exportations arracher
une plus grande indépendance en énergie
par des économies de carburant et le
recours nucléaire cette stratégie a déjà
démarré puisque la france a réussi à
compenser son déficit hors pétrole par
un surplus d'exportation industrielle
mais une telle politique comporte trois
difficultés elle pèse durablement sur la
progression du pouvoir d'achat reste
constamment menacés par de nouvelles
hausses du pétrole comme maintenant et
la modernisation commence par supprimer
certains emplois avant d'en multiplier
d'autres 8e plan qui est centrée sur
l'emploi futur a simplement oublié
erreur psychologique de s'en donner le
titre plan pour l'emploi
raymond barre l'an raymond barre donc en
parlera le premier ministre parlera tout
à l'heure au conseil économique et
social
il assiste actuellement à la séance coup
ce huitième plan a été l'objet de
nombreux débats
si le 1er mai a été célébré d'une façon
générale par les syndicats sur le thème
de la défense du droit de grève des
libertés et même sur le thème des 35
heures de travail par semaine qui vous
en souvenez pour le chancelier allemand
schmitt n'est ni inconvenante comme
revendication ni absurde
on en a pas pour autant oublié les
problèmes les plus concrets et les plus
urgents ainsi pour la sidérurgie
le maire communiste de l'ong oui a dit
comme henri krasucki de la cgt hier à
denain c'est dans les jours qui viennent
que commencera vraiment le combat pour
l'acier à longwy et dans tout le pays et
il a annoncé que la municipalité de
louis fera tout pour soutenir les grèves
en cours dans la sidérurgie
il a d'autre part condamné de façon très
ferme les incidents d'hier autour du
commissariat de longwy
pour ce qui concerne manufrance à une
question qui lui était posée à
l'assemblée nationale le ministre de
l'économie monsieur rené monory a
regretté que les réunion à son ministère
pour constituer la société
d'exploitation avec l'appui financier de
l'état n'ait pas permis d'aboutir à
cause de la défaillance de la
municipalité de saint-etienne c'est
l'expression employée par le ministre
domi et il a confirmé ce si la volonté
de la municipalité de saint-etienne
d'écarter la société des éditions
dargaud de la future société
d'exploitation a dû france risque de
faire avorter l'ensemble du projet il
n'y a pas à l'heure actuelle de
solutions de remplacement a répété le
ministre
et la municipalité d'ailleurs n'en a pas
proposé ce ne sont pas les quelques
flocons de neige tombée aujourd'hui sur
toute la france qui feront rouvrir les
stations de sports d'hiver je ne parle
pas évidemment des stations de haute
altitude où l'on fait du ski toute
l'année en tout cas la saison la saison
est bien terminé et c'est le moment du
bilan des sports d'hiver sur les quatre
millions et demi de français qui ont
pris des vacances à pâques entre le 6 et
le 24 avril 710/1000 sont partis au ski
en france et 100 milles au ski également
à l'étranger
c'est un chiffre encore modeste par
rapport à la population globale
mais c'est tout de même une progrès une
progression tout à fait spectaculaire
dans l'ensemble pour l'ensemble de la
saison d'hiver
le nombre de français ayant séjourné
dans les stations atteint les 4 millions
il y a dix ans cela ne dépassait pas 1
million 250 mille ce développement des
sports d'hiver
c'est accompagné bien sûr d'un
aménagement de la montagne qui pour
démocratiser le ski plus ou moins n'en a
pas moins constitué une atteinte à la
montagne et aux populations qui y vivent
le développement a été souvent
anarchique avec des promoteurs qui ont
joué à l'excès le bénéfice à court terme
aidé en cela par des acheteurs souvent
inconscients qui ont d'ailleurs
découvert la copropriété à la petite
semaine
en quelques années on a vu se construire
des concentrations comme morzine avoriaz
ou bourg chevelle plus de vingt mille
lits les menuires val thorens seize
mille lits ou encore la plagne les arcs
le motard est les supermarchés du ski
avec tout ce que l'as tout ce que cela
comporte
alors va-t-on continuer à créer des
stations de toutes pièces
l'un des derniers exemples c'est
valmorel dans les alpes où on a bien
réussi à intégrer larchitecture dans le
paysage et où on a fait en sorte que les
gens du pays soit très étroitement
associés aux activités du tourisme sans
que cela porte atteinte au patrimoine
agricole
cela dit il existe encore des projets de
super stations de sports d'hiver
on a dit que qu'à coup d'arrêt
leur avait été donné mais on a
l'impression que ça continue alors
voyons nous en sommes
elle avait l'air l'or blanc ignore la
crise avec ses 600 à 700 mille lits la
montagne a affiché complet pendant les
vacances d'hiver ont créé 30 mille lits
chaque année on a multiplié par 5 en 20
ans le nombre des remontées mécaniques
il y en a trois mille en france à peu
près autant qu'en suisse ou en autriche
plus qu'en italie cela ne suffit pas
face à la plus 20% de ski heures
supplémentaires par an et pourtant plus
question selon les pouvoirs publics de
revenir sur une décision qui date
maintenant d'il ya un an et demi
plus question d'équiper la montagne à
tout va on a tiré les leçons des erreurs
passées désordre architecturaux
dégradation des sites et de
l'agriculture perturbations du milieu
écologique constructions en zones
avalancheuse on se souvient de la
catastrophe de val d'isère carence de
gestion les promoteurs d'orcières
merlette par exemple ont laissé une
ardoise de 20 millions de francs au
département des hautes-alpes
le tout sans profit pour les vrais
montagnards généralement exclues de
cette ruée vers l'or blanc depuis
novembre 1977
aucune station ne peut plus être créé
sans l'accord de quatre ministres
environnement agriculture intérieur
tourisme et du délégué à l'aménagement
du territoire
une dizaines d'autorisations tout de
même et en association avec les
collectivités locales est plus question
de stations géante
on penche vers la rénovation de villages
existants de bonnes résolutions qu'il
s'agit de tenir
il faut dire que le domaine skiable ne
couvre que 5 % de nos montagnes et qu'il
ne reste plus guère qu'une dizaine de
sites vierges à équiper comme le
valmeinier près de saint michel de
maurienne jausiers resteront près de
barcelonnette le glacier du rutor à
cheval sur l'italie ou encore le site de
bessines près de l'hospitalet dans les
pyrénées ce râteau conserver ces sites
intacte pour les générations futures
c'est la grande question
il s'est confirmé la semaine dernière
que le rpr n'est pas unie vraiment
derrière monsieur chirac dans sa
stratégie pour les élections européennes
il ya eu la lettre des dix députés dans
le figaro il ya eu l'appel de michel
cointat l'ancien ministre de
l'agriculture pour constituer une autre
liste gaulliste et aujourd'hui il y à
l'initiative de l'ancien ministre
olivier guichard
il a écrit à une cinquantaine de députés
rpr qui d'une manière ou d'une autre
s'interroge ou expriment leur inquiétude
sur la manière de monsieur chirac
commence où mène sa campagne avec des
critiques très vives contre le
gouvernement olivier guichard veut
rencontrer demain c'est 50 députés ce
matin à l'assemblée nationale claude
labbé le président du groupe rpr qui est
aussi le plus proche de jacques chirac a
lancé aux députés gaullistes une mise en
garde contre ce genre d'initiative
répéter peut-on dire ce soir que la
fêlure s'accentue ou rpr patrice duhamel
je crois qu'il faut faire un léger
retour en arrière il y a eu ces derniers
temps la démission du numéro deux du rpr
yves guéna il y a eu au nom du colis ce
même les conditions posées par les
ministre rpr à leur soutien à la liste
chirac debré il y a eu vous venez
différents ludion les mouvements de la
semaine dernière et aujourd'hui il y a
donc l'annnonce de cette réunion à
l'initiative d'olivier guichard ce baron
du gaullisme très proche collaborateur
du général de gaulle ministre du
président pompidou convient donc une
cinquantaine de députés rpr le tiers du
groupe environ à une réunion privée pour
demain en fin de matinée
son but c'est d'examiner les dernières
prises de position de jacques chirac et
la stratégie de l'état major du rpr
olivier guichard il l'écrit à ses
députés n'entend pas créer des
difficultés électorales à la liste du
rpr il ne veut pas prendre d'initiatives
pour l'élection européenne du 10 juin
non il souhaite prendre date et évoquer
les perspectives politiques pour la près
10 juin comme d'autres membres du rpr
olivier guichard est actuellement
troublé par la stratégie de jacques
chirac il a été tout aussi troublé par
la déclaration sur la remise en cause de
la légitimité présidentielle
d'où cette réunion de demain il ne
s'agit donc pas il le dit dans sa lettre
d'une tentative de fractionnement il
s'agit plutôt d'une manifestation
interne d'inquiétude la campagne
européenne provoque donc c'est une
confirmation des remous et des tensions
au rpr
le ton est la nature politique des
propos du rpr du président du rpr semble
également contestées jacques chirac
d'ailleurs dans une interview qui sera
publiée demain matin par le figaro une
longue interview revient sur les propos
qu'il avait tenus la semaine dernière
je ne mène naturellement pas en cause
les pouvoirs et la légitimité du
président de la république dit notamment
jacques chirac je ne les a jamais mis en
cause mais il ajoute il existe au sujet
de l'europe une divergence de fond entre
les deux mouvements qui composent la
majorité présidentielle dès lors dit
jacques chirac si le président de la
république se trouve est identifié aux
idées d'une des deux listes de la
majorité en présence
le risque serait qu'il apparaisse comme
minoritaire dans le pays
c'est pourquoi ajoute jacques chirac
j'ai demandé au chef de l'état de ne pas
engager son autorité dans ce débat en
tout cas jacques chirac qui est
actuellement au québec sera de retour
demain matin à paris et il devra bien
répondre d'une manière ou d'une autre à
ce mouvement de contestation qui semble
s'amplifier à l'intérieur de son
mouvement et que symbolise cette
initiative d'olivier guichard et la
réunion de demain matin c'est donc
demain que les anglais voteront et
choisiront parmi 2500 candidats les 635
députés la chambre des communes cette
chambre était un gouvernable sous
callaghan puisque son parti le 20 le
parti travailliste n'avait pas la
majorité
et tout l'effort des travaillistes comme
des conservateurs consiste à obtenir la
majorité absolue au parlement
de leur côté des libéraux eux tiennent à
leur rôle d'arbitré c'est-à-dire qu'ils
espèrent eux aussi se renforcer pour
apporter leurs voix
selon leurs idées tantôt à l'un tantôt à
l'autre des grands partis on vous a tout
dit hier sur l'incertitude des sondages
les électeurs voteront demain de 7
heures à 22 heures et les résultats
définitifs ne sont connus que vendredi
matin avec andré célarié le dernier
point avant le scrutin après une
campagne où la question européenne et
est souvent mise en avant bien sûr
les travaillistes et les conservateurs
ont un souci commun ils photo vainqueur
une nette majorité car la chambre
introuvable d'hier laisse un mauvais
souvenir qui prendra en fin de semaine
le chemin de danic street et gouvernera
pendant les quatre prochaines années
james khan qui demande aux britanniques
de confort c'est leur adhésion à son
socialisme en anglaise oncle jim qui
malgré le désordre des grèves affirme un
bilan relativement positif et jouit
d'une certaine popularité
margaret thatcher qui demandent un
changement radical de politique
le retour à la libre entreprise la
diminution des impôts et des charges
publiques le renforcement de l'ordre
public
l'arrêt de l'immigration margaret
thatcher dont la popularité a du mal à
dépasser les rangs des conservateurs est
ce que david steel porte parole des
libéraux qui refusent le choix des deux
grands blocs veut introduire la demande
radical dans le débat effectuera une
percée et joue un rôle d'arbitré dans le
futur parlement
car le problème est bien là vous voyez
que les deux grands partis ne dispose
pas de la majorité absolue il leur faut
une victoire nette james cameron veut
renforcer sa majorité il veut éviter de
traîner de vote de confiance en vote de
confiance avec l'appoint de voix de
hasard
la journée de demain n'est pas chômé en
angleterre les bureaux de vote sont
ouverts de 7h du matin à 10 heures du
soir
ainsi chacun pourra voter avant d'aller
au travail ou en rentrant du bureau ou
de lusine on pense que les résultats
seront connus dans la matinée de
vendredi le nouveau parlement se mettra
en place le 8 mai on parle souvent du
fair-play anglais en se demandant s'il
existe toujours et bien oui et je m'en
suis rendu compte en parcourant les rues
de londres et en suivant la campagne des
conservateurs et les travaillistes dans
toute l'angleterre
les anglais ont l'habitude d'exprimer
leurs intentions de vote en affichant
les posters de leur candidat à la
fenêtre ici et là on peut voir à côté
des posters conservateurs les
affichettes travailliste
les mesures de sécurité ont été
renforcées à la chambre des communes
scotland yard veille les candidats eux
mêmes ont été particulièrement protégés
pendant leur campagne en iran la
révolution ne connaît pas de repos et ne
connaîtra pas avant longtemps sans doute
après les deux défilés du 1er mai celui
qui avait lieu derrière les chefs
religieux et celui des syndicats des
forces de gauche
on a pu mesurer les incertitudes de la
révolution mais à côté de cet
affrontement dans un calme relatif
d'ailleurs il ya eu
l'assassinât d'un chef religieux
l'ayatollah motahari tué d'une balle
dans la tête alors qu'il sortait de chez
un ami or ce chef religieux auraient été
encore c'est encore au conditionnel
l'un des membres du conseil de la
révolution l'organe suprême de la
direction du pays
et on pense aussi qu'il a été l'un des
présidents des tribunaux
révolutionnaires islamiques qui ont fait
condamner à mort de nombreuses
personnalités de l'ancien régime et
aujourd'hui encore ces tribunaux ont
condamné trois personnes qui appartenait
à la police l'attentât contre la taille
l'ayatollah motahari a été revendiqué
par une organisation secrète le forgan
inconnu jusqu'à maintenant que
représente ce mouvement terroriste
christian bousquet
le son n'a pas fini de couler en iran
depuis la victoire de la révolution il y
avait ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
terrorisme d'état arrestations
arbitraires jugement exécutions
sommaires des partisans de l'ancien
régime ne se comptent plus et voici qu
apparaît maintenant un terrorisme de
groupuscules et qui s'attaquent au
pouvoir en place en moins de dix jours
deux personnalités proches de
l'ayatollah khomeiny ont été assassinés
par ce groupe extrémiste forgan composée
surtout de musulmans sunnites
cette organisation affirme vouloir
combattre la dictature des mollahs et
des ayatollahs chic
le peuple n'a pas besoin de leaders
affirment les tueurs de forgan une
critique qui visent directement
l'ayatollah khomeini le véritable patron
du pays et ce n'est pas par hasard si
fort ghana choisies pour cibles deux
personnalités très proches d'eux comme
eni le 23 avril dernier c'était le
général gharani l'ancien chef d'état
major de la nouvelle armée iranienne et
la nuit dernière
l'ayatollah montazeri ces deux
assassinats dans le style des brigades
rouges en italie ou de la bande à baader
en allemagne pourrait déboucher sur un
déchaînement de violence dans ce pays où
les armes foisonnent où la sécurité est
assurée par des groupes qui n'obéissent
pas au gouvernement ou le désordre
politique économique et sociale ne fait
qu'empirer
l'état pourra difficilement se poser aux
actions des terroristes de forgan forgan
qui vient d'annoncer que quatre autres
personnalités proche de l'ayatollah
khomeiny dont le directeur de la
télévision
messieurs sa dégringolade et et monsieur
y as dit le nouveau ministre des
affaires étrangères seraient ses
prochaines victimes
la france va annuler les dettes des pays
pauvres les plus déshérités c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le président de la
république tout à l'heure dans une
interview à radio france internationale
le parlement français sera consulté là
dessus mais l'annulation des dettes des
pays pauvres envers la france porterait
sur une somme globale de 600 millions de
francs parmi les pays qui bénéficieront
de cette mesure monsieur giscard
d'estaing inciter les pays les plus
pauvres en effet le mali le niger la
haute volta le tchad la république
centrafricaine la guinée et les comores
tous des pays africains vous l'avez
remarque jean claude narcy les autres
nouvelles de ce journal
succédant aux manifestations syndicales
du 1er mai vous le savez plusieurs des
attentats commis la nuit dernière dans
paris et dans la banlieue parisienne
n'ont pas encore été revendiquées ce
soir sauf six d'entre eux par une
organisation dite de coordination
d'action révolutionnaire organisation
d'ailleurs inconnu des services de
police il y a eu en tout 12 explosions
qui ont visé des magasins et des locaux
de l'administration à toulouse trois
nouveaux attentats ont eu lieu hier ce
qui porte à 15 le nombre des explosions
dans cette ville en un mois les
objectifs visés allant des boîtes de
nuit aux voitures et aux pas aux polices
l'une de ces bombes à d'ailleurs exposé
devant les installations de creusot
loire enfin à montpellier un engin a
explosé devant l'immeuble de la cgt pour
être chaussés de la bourse du travail
l'attend à la non plus n'a pas été
revendiqué deux cent mille emplois
pourraient être créés en trois ans dans
les petites et moyennes entreprises
c'est d'une proposition de loi de l'udf
déposé sur le bureau du sénat ces
mesures consistent en particulier à
permettre aux entreprises de 10 salariés
de recruter deux employés
supplémentaires sans participer au
financement par exemple de la formation
professionnelle ouverture des
négociations de salaires dans la
fonction publique le 8 mai prochain
c'est ce qu'a annoncé aujourd'hui
jacques dominati et cette nouvelle
intéresse plus de 2 millions de salariés
et de retraités
la direction de l'aciérie de sol maire
de fos sur mer dont la production est
arrêtée vous le savez depuis le 8 avril
appellent les employés à reprendre le
travail vendredi matin mais les
syndicats pensent eux que cette reprise
serait hasardeuse
sans le paiement des jours de chômage
technique de la levée des sanctions et
l'ouverture de véritables négociations
lors pulvérise tous ses records le
lingot qui atteint 35 mille deux cent
soixante dix ans gagne 325 francs et le
napoléon et à 299 francs 40 il est en
hausse lui aussi de 4 francs 90 le
conseil des ministres a décidé
d'accroître le nombre de policiers et de
leur dispenser une meilleure formation
concrètement 1300 d'entre eux souvent
employé les tâches administratives
seront remis en service actif 17 n cris
des larmes des éducateurs de
l'administration pénitentiaire au cours
de leur journée d'action ses éducateurs
chargés de la réinsertion sociale des
prisonniers dénonce le manque
d'effectifs ils réclament 100 postes
supplémentaires par an au lieu des 31
accordé en 1979 actuellement pour
l'ensemble des prisons 500 éducateurs
s'occupe
trente cinq mille détenus après les
décisions du président carter concernant
un certain nombre de restrictions
envisagées dans la consommation de
pétrole aux états unis les américains
expérimente une voiture diesel qui ne
consomme que 3 litres 3 aux 100 km en
ville et en pleine circulation
les constructeurs qui ne veulent pas
vendre pour l'instant leurs droits sur
ce moteur se sont vus proposer pourtant
des sommes considérables
les anglais leur en offrait 25 millions
de dollars et au sujet de l'angleterre
la compagnie pétrolière américaine
texaco va réduire de 8% ses livraisons
en grande bretagne c'est une des
conséquences des restrictions envisagées
donc aux états unis quant à la france eh
bien monsieur giraud le ministre de
l'industrie a estimé aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il n'était pas
question pour l'instant de procéder à un
rationnement voilà bien ce journal est
terminée bonne soirée à tous au nom de
toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité le
dernier journal vers 23 heures
en fin de programme avec notre capitale